the strongest driver of pricing power
and profits is supply and demand when we
make content what we're actually doing
is artificially Shifting the demand
curve in our favor and the other side of
this if you are the business owner you
control Supply and so you can inflate
your demand in terms of the amount of
people who want to work with you or buy
from you and at the same time cut your
supply and when you have that happen
price goes through the roof and so do
your profits my goal is to always have
significantly less Supply than I have
demand because that is the Holy Grail of
what you want Which is far more people
who want to do business with you then
you have capacity to do so